hey everybody I'm Scott Butterworth here
with Dave do it at Gamescom 2016 we're
here to talk to you about dishonor
dishonor to yeah you've just got to see
a brand new demo stuff we've never seen
to the game of work it does just overall
just a little bit about what you saw so
we saw Emily going through a clockwork
mansion right which has been teased but
only have really shown much of it yeah
so she was punting a guy called gin bash
he was like The Dukes inventor right but
obviously being a man of intellect his
house this counts is insane right you it
opens up and it's like an open I say
normal mansion as no one can be just
your average manager yeah just look
decadent very lovely but they start
pulling levers and floors just pull away
and disappear and and roofs and ceilings
just vanish and fold away in two ways
that look impossible and then out of the
ground starts coming ornaments and like
a museum pieces and the ruse has changed
completely and then all guarding this
like obviously decadent an impressive
mansion is the clockwork soldiers as
well we're sure which we sort of saw in
the original like teaser announce
swimsuits but this is the first time
we've seen them like like fight and
their days giant mechanical beasts four
swords for arms very tough like that you
can't just jump on one and kill it like
you have to really jam your sword into
its it's inside start prying bits of
gears and nuts out it's it's very
impressive it it's like I'm take a nice
change from the guards that wandering
outside and I'm guessing it takes a bit
of work even to be able to position
yourself to destroy one and he
getting new one it's got to be kind of
challenging how did that play out during
the demo that you saw it was similar to
the way the walkers were the tall boys
and originally decided right they were
really big so it was quite an effort to
get above them and you do the takedown
but you have to do a similar thing
either you have to use the height and
drop down to them or the slide mechanic
and strike them from below where they
can't get the after their sword right so
it's it's you really have tmobile it's
not an enemy you can really go
toe-to-toe with mr. lassen for us we're
blast gonna shrug off and the mansion
from what you can tell was this lake was
it mainly was it puzzle-solving was at
rehearsal like how did how did the
health impact the mission it was more
traversal and kind of avoidance which
was i I was very interested by she
pulled all the neighbors and everything
came up when she entered the mansion but
when the enemies were turning on her
Emily would run away and pull the same
levers which men obviously the house
would revert back to its original state
which men the clockwork soldiers were
blocked off by a wall that wasn't there
before or interest would open up and
they'd fall in so it was it it was a lot
of mobility to it but also you kind of
can use it as a puzzle to your advantage
well being a designer game I'm sure
there are many ways that scenario could
have played out the other big thing
about dishonored of course all the
abilities in Emily being a new
protagonist has all new abilities in
tells about what you saw in this demo so
we saw shadow warg which you've seen for
takes like the shadow bascule form and
she can bring guards up high slice them
in half the Domino which you kind of
link enemies together and they say they
share the same fate right so you tagged
a bunch of different people and whatever
happens in one of them happens to all of
them so you took one guy out all four of
them collapse I faith they pretty much
mean they all die yes auriga choke Dale
you don't have to kill it ready there's
still like the low and high grass or
stolen how high part of the baby the far
reach that's Emily's traversal rather
than covers blink but we also saw a new
power called doppelganger so she creates
a clone of herself basically it wasn't
clear if the clinic could do damage but
it was it was more of a distraction
technique talking to Harvey Smith the
the creator of the game just a couple
weeks ago and he was telling me that
just says in the first game there are
still poetic justice finishes yeah so
you can still choking cladding
snowboarder them or you can find it kind
of storage or weighted
and that seems like a pretty you know
beautiful way beautiful might not be the
right word a good way would take out
yeah same way to take out an inventor
that's you know doing all this poetic
justice yeah interesting all right well
this has been a little bit on Dishonored
2 with Dave to it for more coverage in
Game home 2016 stay tuned to gamespot
com come on he's gone what happened